I see. well, it, it sounds still like there's
a lot, There's a lot of stuff that goes
on from the time that you guys get that
raw data. And you sort of do your quality control,
your QC check before you know, I see it
on my 23andMe profile page. I mean is, is,
is all of that just sort of computational biology
at that point? who, who is looking at that data?
Whose organizing it? What's sort of going on there?
>> Yeah, it really becomes a computational
biology problem once we get the data
from the lab and that's really where
23andMe concentrates. most of our, staff here are
computational biologists, or software engineers so that's
really where we're best. so, the next
major component there is called Calling. That's
turning the data that we get from the
lab into the AAs, AGs, or GGs that you can download in your raw data.
Or produce the reports you see on our website. and that's kind
of an involved process but it in essence relies on looking at these
XY plots. And making sure that everything was where we expect it to be.
>> and so the final results that, that we get back seem to look so,
so curated and so, so official. wha, I mean how much of the computational
sort of side of this is sort of deriving, you know, oh what did this
letter mean. I mean how do you, I mean are you guys viewing all
the literature and, and selecting things and
how, how are those decisions made in general?
>> So we actually have a pretty big
content team at 23andMe. They're the ones who scour
the literature, look at what's going on in the
current science of genetics. And find out this mutation
or this variant causes this disease and it's a
new discovery. Then they would write up what they think
about that and try to put it in a language that makes sense to our users. And if
it meets our scientific criteria, it goes out to
the website. It is all automated it can take time
just to process the data through through to the
website. But the actual process of taking your data, calling
all of the variants and all that is quite
quick. You can think of the website as being in
two parts, there's the part where we, just look
at the calls that you have for a disease. And,
the report just links that call to the results.
Say for example, we could say, you are a carrier
of, of cystic fibrosis because you have this
variant. That's, that's a scientific challenge, to figure out.
>> Mm-hm.
>> What's going on in the literature, but it's not an algorithmic
challenge. The other part of the website includes things like our Ancestry
Composition feature. And our Relative Finder
feature, those are difficult algorithmic problems.
You want to take the whole you know, genotype sample. All million variance
to try and figure out, based on
that, what is this person's ancestral composition.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So you can imagine that that's actually a more complex task and requires a
lot of code taking it from, you know, a, b, c, through to the end.